Ru yangang welcome uh to the show a draw
with the white pieces I see you always
smiling but you wanted to nurture an
advantage out of the opening it wasn't
meant to be tell us your story about
this game yeah um I had prepped Bishop
G4 instead instead like this D Tak C4
line but like I couldn't like I couldn't
do it much I guess like she just traed
like a lot of pieces and like there
there was B G4 here yeah instead of
Knight takes C4 oh no like instead of D
takes C4 on move three got it here
Bishop to G4 this was your preparation
yeah yeah and did she surprise you with
this Knight A4 and queen to A5
specifically um so I had fa this line
like a long time ago uh um but I kind of
forgot what to do after it so like I
just kind of like knew this like Bishop
C4 like this basic idea mhm but yeah
that was it about it yeah and here at
Knight takes E5 Bishop takes C5 Bishop
to D6 there was one opportunity to try
to get something on the king side with
this idea of G4 followed by F4 did you
consider it at
all
um not really I yeah I didn't like
really look at like G4 F4 but it looks
interesting um you do have some
initiative at the same time you are
offering some weakness on the king side
yeah so you wanted to keep the position
close yeah I don't know maybe like Queen
B6 here I I I don't know like oh I can
you play you could play Queen B6 I think
Bishop takes C5 was the best uh and then
B B5 I yeah maybe yeah maybe like my
king is too
weak it did feel like that at the same
time it's kind of a back and forth
situation because you either do
something on the king side with I also
have like F5 ideas that's right that's
right but after that it just simplified
and not much after it right yeah I
couldn't do much yeah ruang you're the
Wild Card coming into this event uh
obviously you know it feels like there's
a little bit of a Target on your back
how do you deal with that what is the
strategy for facing these extraordinary
opponents
um
well I don't I my goal for this turnour
was just like 50% So like um yeah I
don't know I'm just like I'm just trying
not be too stress about every game yeah
that's probably a good strategy
absolutely absolutely congratulations
rang we'll see tomorrow thank you